your thoughts on the stream of headlines
is there an organization of this or is
this a foreign chaos there's a little
bit so look they agreed on a ceasefire
that's going to start midnight Saturday
they agreed to pull back weapons the
crane Ian's are going to pull back their
weapons from their current front lines
the rebels the pro-russian rebels are
going to pull back there they're heavy
machinery from the front lines they had
on sep tember the 19th so they're giving
up some of the their seating some of the
ground that they've taken over the last
few weeks and then it gets muddy and the
muddy part is the political part so the
ukrainian president has agreed to
decentralize power the Russians want
them to federalize the government and in
exchange for doing that giving special
powers to the the east what the the
ukrainian President is hoping for
counting on is he's going to get to
control his own borders he's going to
have Ukrainian troops on the
ukrainian-russian border as opposed to a
separatist that are there now Ryan is it
fair to say that all that has changed
since the September agreement till today
is that Vladimir Putin has gotten more
of what he wants ah that's a good one
you know he's got a little bit more
about what he wants but you know I
wouldn't describe this as an outright
victory because this is a pretty
detailed arrangement there's a real road
map if you will to peace specific stuff
on the ceasefire then road map and
Angela Merkel and Francois Hollande
they've been going to these negotiations
now for months and if this one fails I
think they're going to be pretty upset
and they're going to take action I eat
more sanctions against Russia pretty
quickly Ryan the long-term reform here
is constitutional new constitution for
Ukraine what does the process lay it out
for actually creating that so the
parliaments got together get together
they've got to agree to change the
constitution here's the issue and I
think this is what the whole deal hinges
on what the Russians want is they want
to make sure that Ukraine never becomes
part of NATO and preferably never
becomes part of the European Union so
they want that that region in the East
to be kind of like a buffer state that
would have veto power over federal
government decisions alike doing stuff
like joining NATO and the EU it's not
clear after
heard the Ukrainian president after
those talks that he's a prayer prepared
to give him that much power Ryan a lot
of people are saying that Vladimir Putin
won't stop until he has a land bridge
read Mario poll that gets him to Crimea
yeah well he would be giving that up
here so that's another thing to keep in
mind there would be no land bridge to
Crimea it would simply be the territory
that is controlled now and in fact
there's a little pocket and the Russian
president was talking about this where
the Ukrainians are still hold up six to
eight thousand of them they've been
surrounded by the pro-russian
separatists and the Russian president
was saying those guys better give up
because otherwise it's going to get
nasty even before we get the ceasefire
Ryan an unfair question and we'll let
you go what does a buffer zone look like
I mean is there like fence and walls and
is there like a 30 mile no man's land I
mean what does it look like yeah you
know they have one like that between
Russia and Norway I've driven through it
it's just a desolate area with nobody in
it and our men on either sides probably
no fence at least in the beginning
although the Ukrainians have been
talking for a long time about wanting to
build their own kind of berlin wall to
completely keep militants out but this
would be checkpoints you drive down a
road you get to this checkpoint and
you're turned away and if you try to go
any further there's a good chance
somebody's going to shoot at you okay
Ryan choko thank you so much in the
bloomberg headline folks right now
Brendon Greeley 40 rocket launchers yeah
across from Russia into Ukraine